oh yeah i
can't do this i don't want what oh oh
hi uh sam cedar here and
um i'm i'm just here to congratulate
uh dave pakman on getting
to a million subscribers
so i'm supposed to say something mean
about david pakman
like something you know making fun of
him or something
okay um can i just say something nice
about him because he's a really good guy
and he does a great show
all right listen uh a million people
subscribing to david pakman
a million people press the button saying
we like david pakman and want to watch
him
david pakman's actually awesome that's
what i actually think
sorry i said it david huge
congratulations for hitting
one million followers what a big
milestone and i wish you the best in the
future
david deepak pac-man i just want to say
having known you since you started
making content
just a few short months ago on twitch
it's amazing you've already blown up to
1 million subscribers on youtube
i'm just so unbelievably proud of you
and can't wait to see where your career
goes next congratulations man
uh you and everybody at the david pakman
show man to see that y'all are about to
surpass the 1 million subscriber mark
that's crazy that's a hell of a feat man
so i hope you're proud and you and your
team
yeah man i think you're a very important
voice on the left and i
appreciate you big fan of you uh and
you're welcome to throw any of those
subscribers my way as well my brother
but uh no in all seriousness man
congratulations it's a big feat and it's
always much love
on my end mr david pakman
congratulations on 1
million subscribers
keep on speaking truth to power and
messing up your hair and stuff you're
the best
good job buddy david pakman
congratulations you passed one million
followers i can see why they follow you
because you tell the stories that
corporate media
absolutely can't tell because their
advertisers don't let them tell the
story
because their political contacts don't
let them tell the story
and i think what i've always respected
about you is you step outside of that
you tell the story you tell the back
story you call balls and strikes
and that matters in this business david
so congratulations
keep up the great work i just wanted to
say congratulations to david pakman of
the david pakman show
everybody at the david pakman show
really
for hitting one million subscribers on
youtube that is
phenomenal i gotta say too i kind of
feel like this is
this is really my victory um as
everybody knows i i feel
i've filled in for david many many times
on this program
so i'm not saying it's because of me
but you literally cannot prove that me
filling in for him
isn't what got him to this level so i
guess david and everybody at the david
pakman show what i'm really trying to
say is
you're welcome david pakman
congratulations my friend on 1 million
subscribers david actually was one of
the biggest
helps in getting my show off the ground
david invited me to use his studio i
mean he just kind of all the way all the
way around the board helped me out
however he could
congratulations man on all your success
no telling how many people you've helped
if you help me like that i know you
helped a whole lot of people so
congratulations on all that you do man
congratulations david pakman on hitting
one
million subscribers i don't know how sam
cedar feels about this
no but in all in all honesty uh you are
tireless you work
uh so hard you're so dedicated to the
craft i've known you for years and
uh you have not given up you've been one
of the crusaders in independent left
media and
i really look to you for guidance and
i'm just i'm grateful for your
friendship
and for your voice because i don't know
where we would be as a movement as a
media movement
on the left if it weren't for you so
congratulations well earned
now of course it's not a competition uh
because
i mean if it was a competition i would
have gotten to a million
subscribers before you but it's not a
competition so i didn't feel
like i needed to get there before you
because like i say it's not a
competition david
congratulations a million subscribers
that's such a big number um monumental
achievement
i'm happy for you think about that a
million think about all the effort it
takes
all that subscribing i think it would be
neat to kind of get into that
so that's like uh a million subscribers
let's say it takes half a second
to hit that subscribe button that's 500
000
seconds well that's about 138.8
hours well a million has a nice ring to
it
what's going on david pakman aka david
libman
i just want to congratulate you on the 1
million subscriber marker that you just
reached
i know we have our disagreements on
certain issues
but i value your voice in the
progressive space
especially in independent media keep
moving these
neoliberals further and further left
towards a
social democracy i wish you all the
success in the future
hope to check in again when you have 10
million subscribers
i'd like to congratulate you and your
team david on hitting
1 million youtube subscribers it's an
incredible accomplishment and a result
of a tremendous work ethic as well as
which potentially might be even more
impressive
the ability to brush off the hate and
toxicity that is
rampant particularly in american
politics all the best
for health and all the best for success
in the future
you should be very proud of yourself uh
well-deserved
um i mean not as deserved as maybe other
uh competing shows but it's not a
competition so
uh as you can see uh david pakman
congratulations
one million subscribers you are big time
i mean not that much bigger than
than than my show but big time